Kendall Jenner and Haley Bieber shut
down those Feud rumors with a little fun
in the sun you betcha over the weekend
Haley shared this snap lounging with her
pal smiling and giving a big thumbs up
to the camera sarcastically writing
feuding in quotes along with a series of
heart emojis everything's like so good
right now and I'm very happy the post
comes shortly after rumors surfaced that
there was beef between the besties after
they vacationed in Europe separately oh
my God just be cool it's fine but guys
besties are allowed to take trips with
other friends and clearly there's
nothing but love between them in fact
they've been thick as thieves for over a
decade
cheers
back in 2021 they opened up about their
friendship when Kendall appeared on an
episode of Haley's YouTube series who's
in my bathroom explaining they first met
at the Hunger Games Premiere in 2012 and
knew each other through Kendall's little
sis Kylie Jenner I love you both but you
and I became much closer because you
started modeling and coming to New York
all the time and I lived in New York and
you needed a friend yeah you were my
only New York friend and boy did we take
that City by storm it's kind of hard not
to have fun doing it since then fans
have seen them go on fancy getaways
attend the Met Gala and sick courtside
at basketball games with Haley's hubby
Justin Bieber but they insist they're a
lot more low-key IRL what's funny is I
think that people actually think we have
this like really abnormal friendship
abnormal abnormal like we do all this
like crazy together when the
reality is like we just sit at home and
drink wine or watch movies like it's so
normal people don't even understand how
normal it is it means something to me as
for what makes their friendship work I
think the best part about us is that
we're like I know it's corny to say but
like yin and yang like we're so opposite
that we like almost balance each other
out in a way yeah I think that it's kind
of as simple as that I feel like we've
both seen each other like Thrive at
different times than others do you know
what I mean and we've been there for
each other through it all and not like
let it get in the way of our friendship
which I think is really like special and
important the verdict on this case a
potential friend falling out false
[Music]
foreign